طبعا هنا في قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
الجهه الاخرى في موقع اخر وموقع مختلف
ووصول سفينه جلاله الملك ابها تابع للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه التي تقل
او تم اجلام 200
وثلاثه اشخاص من بورتسودان الى قاعده
الملك فيصل البحريه هنا في جده طبعا قبل
قليل شاهدنا نزول
او عمليه اجراء الدفعه الاولى من عمليه
الاجلاء الى هنا على الرصيف قاعده الملك
فيصل البحريه ايضا في انتظار وصول المزيد
من
ممن وصلوا على متن هذه السفينه مراحل عده
يتم التاكد من اول اوله والتاكد من سلامه
وصحه من هم على متن السفينه ومن هم تم
اجلاؤهم من قبل الصحه السعوديه وبعد ذلك
يتم
التاكد من معلوماتهم وايضا
انتقالهم الى المرحله الاخرى عبر حافلات
خصصت وبعد ذلك الى مقر سكني الهند طبعا في
هذه الحاله ايضا او في هذه علامتنا هذه
السفينه ايضا عده جنسيات مختلفه سوف تتضح
لنا بعد قليل ولكن العدد
المتاكدين منه هو اكثر من
203 اشخاص هم ممن وصلوا على متن هذه
السفينه طبعا ما زلنا نرصد عمليات وصول
الاجلاء ولكن نشاهد فرحه الواصلين وفرحه
اول من وصل على هذا الرصيف ونشاهد هنا
فرحتهم لو نلتقي بعض الصور
للتعبير عن فرحتهم ويبدو انهم من الجنسيه
الاندونيسيه ولعل الجنسيه الاندونيسيه حتى
الان هي المستحوذه على اكبر جاليه او اكبر
عدد من الرعايه الذين يصلون الى السعوديه
او الى جده تحديدا اليوم وصلوا اكثر من
واليوم نشاهد ايضا دفعه جديده ودفعه اخرى
تصل الى هنا عبرها السفينه جلاله الملك
ابها في انتظار المزيد من الوصول طبعا
ايضا من الواصلين في هذه اللحظات ايضا بعض
الرعايه الصين ونشاهد ايضا الملحق العسكري
الصيني نشاهد هنا في الجهه الاخرى نشاهد
ايضا رعايه الصينيين الذين وصلوا قبل قليل
وكذلك ايضا بعض الرعايه من السودان
وجنسيات مختلفه سوف تتضح لنا عند وصولنا
او عند نزولهم سوف تتضح لنا بشكل اكبر
طبعا الورود وكذلك الفرحه بالنسبه
للواصلين ليس فقط هم فرحتهم ولكن ايضا
فرحه من هم موجودون هنا من القوات البحريه
الملكيه السعوديه
وكبار وصغار من الجنسين يصلون على متن هذه
السفينه السفينه جلاله الملك ابها واحده
من السفن التي
تقوم باجلاء عده رعايه من الجنسيات
المختلفه الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
هناك ثلاثه مواقع يتم اجلاء فيها رعايه
الجنسيات المختلفه في مدينه جده نتحدث عن
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه التي نتواجد
فيها ونتحدث ايضا عن قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه والتي ايضا
كانت العربيه ترصد وصول عمليه اجلاء لوصول
عدد من
الرعايه الكوريين وكذلك ايضا نتحدث عن
ميناء جدا الاسلامي والتي والذي كنا
نوافيكم فيه في بعض تفاصيله عند عمليه
اجلاء الصينيين قبل او خلال الساعه
الماضيه في الجهه الاخرى
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات